hello everyone welcome back to the
channel this time around we're talking
about the new texas chainsaw massacre
movie on netflix with fede alvarez how
you doing my friend i miss talking to
you
not good all good
all right
we
must start at uh i guess by going back a
little because you're no stranger to uh
bringing back iconic car franchises so
were there any lessons learned on evil
dead that you were able to apply to this
new texas chainsaw movie
yeah definitely that that mantra of that
film that was to do everything practical
to do everything on camera right um i
think it would be a terrible sin to take
something a title like that a title like
evil data and or texas chains of
massacre and then suddenly having this
like a digital look or just something
that feels like
too
modern in a way or too technological
when it comes to effects i don't have
some cg character oh my god right like
it's the last thing you want to see
and um i think i always take a sloppy
crazy like kind of slightly
campy
special effects than any like polish
like uh super high-end uh vfx right okay
and i think that's what the audience
wants to see as well and as a fan you
want the real deal so that was
definitely one of the lessons only
because we we saw how that pay off and
people always loved that and still today
that's what they talk about when i talk
about that film so on on day one of this
film production i spoke with david
bluegrass like
that's just one rule you know like that
there's no fake blood in this dojo right
like it's gotta be all real and um and
he was like yes sir and and they went
for that so so anything really
translated it's a lot of work it's a lot
of work it's one of those things that
simple to say but hard to do really
because then it's a mess on set every
day and the resets are nightmare and
it's like it's a nightmare for everybody
involved but i think that's what makes
the the fun nightmare for the audience
right thank you for going through all
that trouble you've got some gnarly and
like beauty i think i called evil dead
beautiful too and it applies here too
like beautiful gore i love it
uh talking a little bit about the early
stages because probably no surprise i've
been following this film for quite a
while now so i know things changed a bit
early on in production so can you kind
of give us a sense of what the biggest
difference between what was shot by the
original directors and what we get in
the final version of the film is
there there was nothing uh
they did didn't get do you really shoot
much i think you shot it for a couple of
days and and that's what realized it was
going to be it wasn't going to be the
way we wanted and um and and and the
thing changed but um so there's nothing
there might be i think there's one there
might be one scene in the movie
i think at the very beginning when
uh
when lila goes and talked with richter
and they have the gun i think that's
what they shot and i think they did a
great job i think that that's a
beautiful scene and that that is the
only thing then the rest um
it's all david yeah
i'm just going to put up the spoiler
warning now we're going to run this
after the movie is available and i want
you to be able to talk about all this
other stuff freely right now but
bringing up that particular scene it
makes me think you know like one
significant story element element to
this movie that really stands out to me
is the choice to address gun violence so
can you kind of kind of walk us through
you know how that element came to be for
this movie and how you settled on this
particular way to incorporate it um the
the way we see it and the way we work
with this themes is really it's just
based on this it's we i'm uruguayan
right so i'm not i'm not from here so
i'm i was not born in the states i came
to the states the first time when i was
an adult and uh and i moved to the
states just
recently maybe right after evil dead
2013 or something like that so so
there's there's a few themes just that
are constantly in the news and people
they just slap you in the face as soon
as you move here because there are
things you never discuss
in your country right those are usually
the things that are in the movie
and it is so the move so in a way for us
as writers we kind of we put all these
themes that you're kind of trying to
thinking also about an international
international audience you're kind of
trying to explain them it's like almost
like if you're going to another planet
you're trying to explain what's what
happens in america and you're going to
go well
there's this obsession with guns and
there's this gun violence and and they
have all these issues with this and this
and that and that and that and just talk
about the things that normally is not is
if there are very american issues that
that you don't that i at least i didn't
deal with um where i was where i'm from
so in a way it's like we're trying to
put all these things in the movie
and trying to have letter face
represents the hate that comes out of
that right it's uh
it's
it's for me he represents that hate
that come from fear not the hate that is
intellectual if you watch the original
movie he's just like a kid that's scared
that sees his people walking to his
house and
and suddenly are terrified and he's
terrified of them and he doesn't
understand why they're wearing the
clothes they're wearing and and where
they came from it just start killing
them i don't think
and it definitely out of some sort of
like fear and hate combined so i think
is that it is what letter face is like
the product of the tensions that create
they come out of all the themes in the
movie that that's that was the way you
see it um
so that's and and in a way also i think
definitely
you you do a movie that's called texas
chainsaw matching some massacre just in
this day and age i think it was it
wasn't going to be called a massacre by
just killing five people and
and and the shooting in a way at the
beginning kind of shows that the fact
that is you know we live in a in times
where massacres do happen um and and
that's why i think it also even the
movie he needed to help the annie to to
earn the title the the word massacre in
the title and not being just by people
and just take it to the level of what
happened in the boss scene right um but
uh but that that is
our instinct with roto it's like to
really
it becomes such an american title to
bring all the themes into it and try to
confuse the [ __ ] out of you you know
with them try to really not make them
clear and black and white you know
that's that's why we didn't don't
breathe it was also talking about
america and detroit representing a part
of america
and really trying to make it so clear
that well these are the bad guys these
are the good guys this you know there's
this theme there's two sides of it these
people are wrong these people are right
that that's that's not because that's
not how the world worked for us it's
just the world is [ __ ] messed and
it's a great shades of grey and and they
could be all sort of characters in both
sides of the story so that that's the
way we approach it we want you to walk
out of it and go like wait but i'm still
don't have an answer who was right and
wrong
and and and because that that is
the way life works um and i know that
some movies do give you an answer and
they take a strong point of view for us
in something like takes a chainsaw
massacre it's a [ __ ] harm like a
jurors gruesome horror movie it got got
to be chaotic and it cannot be preachy
like you know it's not school time right
bringing up how leatherface responds to
all these situations so the movie didn't
necessarily need this but when i get
obsessed about something i've got to
know every little detail so did you ever
come up with any backstory on how
virginia at the orphanage kind of kept
leatherface under control while he was
living with her
yeah and i don't think she did i mean
honestly if it was your original saga
because this movie is part of that
original saga that ran
from the first movie until the last one
before the reboot of nispo right and and
in all those movies um up to next
generation i mean they they
he never really dies i mean you could
say at the end of part two there's a
grenade and but but you don't really see
the body like like and every other movie
that star says like well he never really
got caught and none of the family got
caught they always like keep reset so
the way we saw it was like he he would
probably run away after the events of
the first movie he went into the
orphanage like you know he didn't go too
french he got
he hid in some barn somewhere like mama
find him there like covering blood
scared to death
understood he was he saw he was mentally
challenged he understood he was abused
by this family and said like okay i
gotta give this guy a break and uh then
take him in
and took him in and but i don't think he
stayed there because otherwise the other
move those movies wouldn't have not
happened i think you know it's just that
guy that gets in in and out of rehab you
know like i think he stayed there
sometime then he went out for the events
of part two then went back home then
went out and then at some point when he
was when he was older he just
you know his leg that bad leg wouldn't
work anymore and he's like [ __ ] i just
have to stay here and just stay put and
and he's been a good boy for quite a
while and mama has kidnapped finally
keep him there for for for a long time
until the events of the movie but that
that that's the way i see it
hopefully there's no i mean someone's
going to find a crack in that but at
least that's the way
for now i'll tell you i buy it i'll
squeeze in one more question here um
so we have to talk about sally of course
and i know you've said that and you kind
of just said it in your last answer too
that this movie isn't necessarily meant
to erase the events of all of the
previous films and it certainly doesn't
feel like that in the end but the one
big story detail that it really does
change is sally's situation so how did
you uh come to the conclusion that this
movie needed her return in it and also i
guess necessitated her experience since
the original killings be changed
yeah i mean it's it
it was
the challenge for us was how do we we
definitely wanted to see that encounter
just mostly because
it was
the character sally was there to kind of
echo what could be
what could happen to lila you know
someone that was a victim of violence
when she was young and um
and obviously i think for me sally is
not a good example of what what should
happen to that person she's just
consumed by it and just spend the whole
whole life trying to find closure by
just enacting more violence right and
and and i think that's
there's a moment that when i love in the
film when she's you know when she has
reached her you know the at the end of
her story um and she and she tells laila
that that she has to stop running she'll
be hunted all all her life that she
gotta they gotta take the different
action right that she's just runs and
and scared like then she'll be hunt by
that idea all her life and she does
something about it she does what she
thinks she needs to do um so she was
there mostly to echo like what could be
like represent what lilac could turn
into in the future and and change her
the curse of her story
but at the same time as you know the
standalone way i think she was there
also to find it an ending that was more
unconventional in a way
that i think
if i would if that you know if anything
if any of us confront
you know what whoever is your
devil in your life that person that did
something terrible to you or that you
know being a big thing or even being
just some
boyfriend girlfriend that just dumped
you and and cheated on you you hit the
the day and you spend your life thinking
a day that i find a guy just gonna not
get tell him until he's gonna hear it
um in reality
you
never goes anywhere you just don't find
the words and whatever you do doesn't
change anything because it's a change
has to come from within no not based on
that encounter right so in a way i think
that's what she discovered in the story
when she finally met him she realized
she's not sure what she wants to do
she's to kill him would be
anti-climatic voice not what she was
looking for just like blow his head off
she wouldn't find any nothing on that so
i think what she finds is that she wants
to be acknowledged that she wants to she
wants him to understand what she did to
her but obviously he's not gonna give
her [ __ ] like he's not that guy he's
like he barely remembers her that's the
way we see him see like he doesn't even
know who she is
she spent all her life thinking about
him the guy doesn't even know she is
which is very different from halloween
in a way that as well that having had
that movie coming out so recently i want
to make sure that it was a completely
different story in that movie like
michael's obsessed with her and that
that makes her a big deal and it can
make her feel you know well he's
obsessed with me this is completely
opposite he's like the guy that gives
[ __ ] about her and and makes her journey
like completely pointless and
and that's what i think is is it's more
interesting at least in his schedule
you're like what the [ __ ] just happened
which again is my it's what i want to
have people frowning going like what the
[ __ ] going on it's one of my best
reactions
that reaction shot from her when she
realizes that he doesn't remember like i
didn't expect my heart to crumble that
late in the movie when so much blood had
been shed so i dug that beat quite a bit
all right i'll let you go i know you got
a lot to do today congratulations on the
movie and hurry up and make more so we
could talk again soon
good thank you barry
you